so my first kind of a point i want to
leave with you is really to understand
who you are
because you will be tested
through all this period of time
do your future career development
that you're going to really have to
really face to to to ask yourself
whether your value investor you're not
value invest
now if for whatever reason that your
personality is built to be a value
investor
that probably means that you're somehow
you know
genetically mutated throughout the
the process of evolution
that a you're very comfortable being in
a minority
which is not really very uh
natural to human beings you know
throughout our human evolution process
the most of us survive it because we
stick with the group
in phase of large mammals that's the
only way we can we can survive and so it
is really over
you know
tens of thousands of years of
evolution it really is you know deeply
ingrained into your genes
uh but occasionally you will find a
small percentage of people really
survive despite the fact that they
really have a different kind of a gene
it's almost through a mutation process
that that group of people survived
so that's the first thing you have to
really be very very comfortable uh
you know
being
very much by yourself
and therefore you would naturally adopt
attitude or write
not because other people agree with you
but because your reason your evidence
are right
it is common sense but of course as
people said common sense is at least a
common commodity
most people don't think that way
and secondly
that you would probably spend most of
your time
truly being an academic researcher
instead of so-called a professional
investor
most of the time you're going to spend
as a professional investor
as a value investor not a professional
investor is really to be an academic to
be a researcher to be a journalist
actually
to basically be have
insatiable curiosity
to really and try to figure out
how just about everything works
because investing really the more you
know
the better off you are as an investor
and so you you just have to be
naturally interested and curious
just about everything
any kind of businesses politics
science technology uh
humanity history poetry literature
everything really affected your business
basically
so you almost have to wait
you know
i don't want to scare off people
you don't have to put it away
it will help you
it will help you
and then occasionally you want to find a
feel insight that all of those studies
that really give you tremendous
opportunities
that other people just for whatever
reason couldn't deal with
either psychologically somebody said or
because of the limitation of the
thinking or because of the institutional
imperative of the institution they
belong to all sorts of different reasons
and then you go through
find out is the business
that opportunity you're given is that
cheap
is the business a good business is the
management is somebody that i can trust
either because they're good or because
the external checks are sufficient
and what else is missing and why this
opportunity presented to me so you go
through all this checklist and you feel
comfortable and then you just have to
really go over the last psychological
barrier
to basically do it
hello guys thanks for watching the video
now first i will share with you my notes
and then some personal reflections
first of all you have to be comfortable
being in the minority
and be almost by your own
most of your time you gotta be an
academic researcher instead of the
so-called professional investor
because you cannot just scratch the
surface
but you have to go deep into the
business and understand at the
fundamental level
you also gotta have an insatiable
curiosity towards multiple disciplines
such as economics politics biology
history psychology
among others that will help you on
building a unique insight on the
businesses you're analyzing
when you find an opportunity you see if
it is actually cheap you see how good
the business and the management is and
after all this you also have to go
through the psychological barrier of
actually do do it and
buy the into the position
it's important also that you nurture an
attitude that you're right not because
other people agree with you but because
your evidence is right independent
thinking
i believe that nowadays thanks to the
internet the path for the value investor
is not as lonely as in the past
over the years i have discovered
communities here in youtube but mainly
in twitter
in the so-called community fin tweet
therefore i believe now there is more
support to endure the harsh but
profitable path of a value investor
in other talks lilu has also mentioned
that one of the most important qualities
for an investor is to keep intellectual
honesty
this means that you should not buy
positions that are outside your circle
of competence
and haven't done the appropriate
research
as richard feyman famously said
you must not fool yourself and you are
the easiest person to fool
[Music]
okay guys that was all for today
thanks again for watching the video and
if you found the content valuable
please subscribe and give us a thumbs up
to hopefully reach other people like
minded
you